look who's here
mr. TV the omnipresent mr. mogill
Michael Strahan Fox NFL Sunday analyst
GMA co-host also the executive producer
of a show on the audience channel
DirecTV religion of sports that we'll
talk about it's good to see again do too
bad
and met your son yeah yeah handsome
fella yeah they kept saying he looks
like his father I'm like no he doesn't
yeah you should never put that on the
kid but you look like you've slimmed out
my son looks like he's about the same
size as your son's taller than me but
they huh well yeah how much you weigh
now - 4:45 what was your buddy a when
you play 280 something when I came
another rookie I was like 250 something
they say we got to put on weight they
don't tell you to eat right they just
say put on weight so it was like a
passport to the worst food in the world
so I was like 285 I felt like a engorged
tick I could not move I couldn't do
anything so every year just kind of
started losing weight in my last three
years I was between every Friday we
weigh in 252 to 248 right there not much
off what I used did you get fined if you
were overweight and like $300 a pound
but it has to be it was even if you were
like - if your weight was 250 and you
were 250 and 2 ounces yes you got to
lose that two ounces go use the bathroom
or something but you got to use it
wait loser yeah could you get fine for
two ounce yeah you get fine 300 bucks
because that two means a pal and this is
Tom Coughlin yeah yeah he was a very
forgiving coach looking back retrospect
did he make you better
absolutely love him when I had my first
meeting with him and I walked out of the
first meeting and I said to myself
Island I'm doing one year this guy will
never play for me again one year I'm
done I can't I'm not gonna play with
this for this guy can't
and now after I retired I said if I ever
had to go back I could only play for him
it changed we change you
understood what he was his philosophy
about teamwork and and he had to learn
to treat you other human being because
he very much you know you're a football
player and everything all about football
but once he showed that they were the
family side and he understood he was
seeing with his grandkids you were seen
with other players your players kids and
you're like why or why don't we get that
guy we get the chroman but why did you
go kicking and screaming you and Tiki
and it felt like there was this I didn't
kick and scream like Tiki I love teacher
but I think but why why did Tiki have
such a problem with Tom Coughlin I don't
know I just think he was at a point
where he wasn't in the mood to forgive
and I was at the point where I I think I
realized that Tom and I had the same
objective we wanted to win and we just
thought about in two different ways but
once we got on the same page then we we
found hey we both want the same thing so
I was eager to forgive as long as they
helped the team win and thank goodness I
stuck around long enough but you look at
the the world of coaching now of what is
permissible you know could Vince
Lombardi coach today no no you couldn't
I was talking to one of the players who
I played with came out with me in 93 was
now a coach and I said man how's it
going he goes it's great it's
frustrating
Hawaii goes the modern player these guys
are out there dancing and prancing and
it's just I think it's a softer league
right now as far as the the way that the
guys go about practice the way that you
know the hold the structure of the you
can't hit you can't put on your pass
that for once a week and the only 17
practices and pass throughout the year I
would still be playing personally I'd be
like year 28 right now or something if
it were like that because it's a totally
different mentality I think that what
you had to have back in mind in my time
I don't want to be that old guy like
back in my day did you leave at the
right time yeah absolutely
15 years but I get so many people come
up Dominica would you quit so early 15
years that's that's an eternity yeah and
then when I look I didn't realize that
place that long until I you know I sit
there with Howie and I sit there with
Terry and like I played 13 years 12
years I'm going man and why was that
dumb enough to stick around for 15 I
must have been somewhat insane
but it's a long time but I joined I
enjoyed it and I finished on a high note
and there was no need for me to go back
you look at today's players though with
Colin Kaepernick with what he's doing
her Cam Newton what he's doing her Josh
Norman what he's doing the role that
veterans play can they play this same
role to take somebody young under their
wing and and guide them absolutely does
Cam Newton what he listened to somebody
or what Josh Norman listen to somebody
if they're smart if they're smart and
and I think now with the way the NFL is
set up there aren't very many teams with
that kind of that now yeah because the
salary cap and the way you can get a
younger player to come in and play for a
lot less than what you have to pay for a
vet minimum you're not gonna have that
same type of leadership so you have a
lot of guys who are great players and
who are good guys I don't want to take
that area are good guys but sometimes
don't understand it till there's there
don't know what they don't know would
you put up with Odell Beckham
celebrations um some of them like some
of it I would say hey like okay you you
kiss the net once okay we're good don't
marry it the next time and then next
thing you know you have babies running
around with a net like once as good we
get it and then some of the stuff you
take your helmet off in it and it
penalized as a team I don't like that I
understand you're excited we're all
excited for you but you have to learn to
do something that's gonna and in the
context of the team and not just you
don't look at me but he's a phenomenal
player and I do is understand emotion
but you have to think it's bigger than
you that's the best of minds that you
have to have in order to be a winning
team it's bigger than one person yeah
but they're doing it for your your son
like like so if you're 23 the kids who
are 12 think you're awesome they're not
doing it you know so somebody like me is
gonna go hey boy stop do you I'm the guy
who yells at you to get off my like they
look at me as probably saying don't you
get it
but see this is where I hate coming
across as like the the player guy who
played and he's like hating on the young
guys I'm not that guy I totally get it I
was there you know
with guys a lot younger than me and I'm
very understanding because I felt like
once you start thinking you know it all
that's when it you know is when you're
fooling yourself so I understand the
excitement I understand what fits in
with these younger generation absolutely
totally get it but I also think at some
point you got to look back at yourself
and realize how how it really does look
I mean and I just don't I understand the
dancing sometimes
you get it first no I used to flex
everyone so I get a sack I've done flex
on it I kept it pretty simple yeah yeah
I wouldn't I wouldn't answer
did anybody yell at you for flexing no
because if they did that second who did
you not suck man that you wish yeah I
don't know you know more so than I would
love to sack some of these young guys
like a quarterback I would love to have
tried to he go after cam I would dare
I'd act Prescott cams bigger than you
yeah yeah but when I put on this
everybody was bigger than me man I was
257 pounds but once I put on those
shoulder pads I felt like I'm the
biggest baddest sob on the planet they
switch if I gave you a blind hit or you
could go they knew you were coming and
they're coming right you're right in
their sternum so you can pick somebody
how are you gonna hit him how am I gonna
hit you want to go blind or you know I
don't care if you see me coming I'm
still gonna hit you you know how many
times the quarterback like he sees you
coming he throws the ball and I'm like
one step away and I'm like well I know
you threw it but I was close to the
huddle with you so yeah you know I take
my chances I take my chances I see how
they played it because it's all about
the hit and sometimes it's if you follow
through too much or if you the way you
finish your body language like in down
the kazoo and he stepped on them and
rolled a step on his stop but you don't
stomp on a guy straight out you like
accidentally step and you roll slowly
off your toe from heel to toe on the
hand during the commercial break could
you do that to Paulie
like just show us how you would do that
no probably volunteered did you ever you
don't have to be told to take somebody
out no no no I didn't ever wanted to
take anybody out I just wanted to play
hard but did you guys have a bounty now
it as far as incentive not the word
bounty but would you say alright whoever
gets this guy we're all buying dinner no
no no we are guys were too cheap would
you tell me if you actually had
incentive to take somebody on yeah I
don't think we we never we weren't that
kind of team we weren't anyone to play
hard and you want to be respected and I
was never one I never wanted to take
anybody out I want to beat you with your
best players I don't want any excuses
but I don't we didn't have bounties like
that but as many times you guys hit
Brady in the Super Bowl you did try to
take Brady out no we just we just tried
to win the game we were hitting him so
often and so fast from the beginning of
that game we're looking around like okay
they something they're tricking us like
they're tricking us this is not Mainers
setting us up so they we can rush so
fast and they'll throw a screen over our
head or something but then we realized
once he was cursing out the line this is
real he's not cursing these guys out for
nothing he's kind of pissed that we're
getting to him that's a big advantage
for you guys oh yeah because now all of
a sudden you're starting to see cracks
in the armor with the undefeated team
and yeah but one thing about him as
opposed to a lot of other quarterback
because one thing when is no better
feeling as as an athlete when you know
you're dominating a team or some guy so
much that you can look in his eye you
could tell he's like I don't want to be
here and and Brady never had that look
some of his guys he never had that look
and that's the one thing I respect about
him this guy's he's a competitor man and
it's pretty as here there's beautiful as
his family is there's pretty wife you
know quarterback throughout pretty women
he is a fierce competitor and I think we
all walked out of that game when I was
winners of course but would a lot more
respect for him in that in that aspect
who wind though who whined and whined I
don't know why during the game you sack
him
I don't know who wine but I just miss I
do miss the noises they made it's not I
mean I you like you hit a quarterback
and just here like like life guys I
missed that but I don't know if anybody
really wind because if you were wine and
then we're really regatta try to give
you a little some your own better said
that he ran over a guy and he actually
heard him whimper he said he goes he
goes I felt bad because I I mean he
tried to tackle me and I ran him over
and I could just hear this I said bus I
understand that man
no he did not name names Michael Strahan
putting on a clinic how to get away with
things after you get up off the pile
there how to get away with mud yes so
you're stepping on Pauly's hands so when
the linemen would be on the ground you
would just you might get a piece of his
hand when you're standing standing up
you might put your knee into his stomach
when you're getting up and slowly put
your foot on his whatever you may get
your foot on and just kind of push down
very hard and roll off it down date a
little screen people talk about Larry
Allen that defensive players would get
the Larry Allen flu oh you caught Allen
itís I never you never you big boy
you wait 350 you don't run fast enough
to pull a groin why was Larry Owen so
bad cuz he was just he was it's like a
block of granite
I mean guy was wider than this desk he's
the strongest guy in the NFL he was me
it just may even say anything you know
yeah it's one thing right when somebody
talks smack he talk smack don't get me
fired up huh
Larry you say something he did he was
out so Larry was just he was very
intimidating and very strong and once he
got got his hands on you with over yeah
who's the other lineman though
who gave you trouble we're not that you
would get the flu what no I wouldn't get
the flu I think the only guy who every
time I consistently went up against him
I was like oh boy this this could go
either way
it was Larry's teammate here's a guy
right next to him you know Eric Williams
oh because Eric was mean
Eric was mean man like like he was a
nicest guy off of the field but on the
field that was the meanest dude I've
ever encountered
yeah and I'm always used to watch too
and they used to play you know Green Bay
Packers and Reggie White rest in peace
was there and he's playing Reggie and
Reggie with a preacher we all know that
the minister of defense that nicest guy
Reggie white out there just saying you
know the Lord is coming and then he sack
your quarterback but he wasn't gonna
fight anybody
Eric Williams every time they played
ready wife's trying to fight him you got
the preacher out there a man of peace is
that the trying to fight you
it shows how crazy he was cuz you even
throw the ball and if you turn to look
instead of chasing after he just punch
to the back of the head and they throw
the flag and he would go okay I don't
mean anything imma do it again
he was just intimidating he's Michael
Strahan he and Tom Brady and Gotham
Chopra are the executive producers of
religionist sports it's a six-part
documentary series it premieres tonight
at 8:00 Eastern and Pacific exclusively
on audience on both the DirecTV and AT&T
u-verse what what can we expect out of
this documentary well Tom Brady and I
finally teammates oh and Gotham you know
Gotham Chopra Deepak son he and I got
together years ago talked about working
on something and this is like something
that has been in the back of his mind I
guess in his heart for a long time and
it explores sports in a different way
not just okay this is a great sports
story about this athlete or this is
about the athlete the arena or the stage
that is set in in the fan and we we find
out how sports transcends just
entertainment for people how kind of can
can shape or cultures or or a community
and it doesn't have to be the biggest
sport in the world
but we did NASCAR which is really an
amazing story about how it helped the
soldier who was the Afghanistan lost
both legs how it helped him come back
from that and his the melding of man and
machine because he talks about growing
up that was the biggest thing for him
and then he's talking about man and
machine and how a NASCAR is the ultimate
bond of that and then you see him
walking up to metal legs but we have
Dale Earnhardt jr. than that as well and
Kurt Busch and just that's how the fan
tied them with the sport and ties in
with the athlete we do dust out the
Calgary Stampede something that you know
I never understood but now it gives you
a great understanding of man and beast
and and why it's so important
the rise of USC I mean cats igano we do
incredible story on her and why you know
why would this woman want a fight like
this when you see her life you'll see
why she fight for a greater purpose and
then you see why these fans are so tied
in to that we even do a games eSports
guys sitting these are it and I'm like
eSports now I get it
I'm usually telling my kids get off the
computer stop playing those games boy I
get it and they're the prizes of a
millions of dollars yeah and people will
just sit and watch gamers yeah yeah in
like Staples Center yes and it's
unbelievable so like and if you think
about sports and religion have such a
tie because it gives you such some
people is such a feel like the arena is
the chapel you know the demigods could
be a city athletes and the spectators
are the parishioners and we just try to
tie all that in together to give your
deeper look into how your sports affect
life throughout the world not just in
our country were you religious prior to
games oh yeah you pray yeah yeah they
pretty much the whole team you know you
have the Lord's Prayer and you do all
this stuff and and you I definitely pray
to myself I mean did for myself
yeah dad on right I did hey man it's
about to go down out there
Holly brought this up and let me see if
you agree with this he said if now
demeanor was if Jay Cutler had two Super
Bowls he would be like Eli
and vice-versa facial expressions if
you're watching Cutler in Eli is there
much difference in how they look after
they've thrown an interception or this I
think there's just different they bought
something different a different feel I
don't know what it is like like their
body language is I gotta say body
language sometimes is I said I should
actually get upset with that and I had
talked to Coughlin about it I said you
know yeah I know he's young and I know
but he's one of our leaders the body
language is killing me man I mean I'm
still trying to be positive and he's
looking at you know just kind of looking
out into the Stars but then I realized
it's perfect for New York he just has
that okay it kind of happened I got to
move on to the next no I feel like what
was main would have fit in that demeanor
would have fit in more with New Yorkers
and Eli would have fit in an
Indianapolis a little bit more well you
could say that - yeah that would be fair
to say but I just think that Eli worked
here because it's almost as if people
are like okay we're just not gonna get
on the guy because he doesn't even care
he just had that boom so did you want
him to be angry and throw his helmet and
not that I wanted him to be angry but to
me if you throw a pic don't walk off
like that you know lift your head up man
you know look look confident steel do
you have an Eli face you'll have an Eli
face but he would Cutler I don't know
just a body language of Cutler
Eli gives the body language of oh man I
just disappointed people whereas Cutler
give the body language of well I just
did the point of pity but I don't give a
damn it's a different feel different
different thing but you see Peyton the
way he is in Eli and their brothers and
they're completely completely different
right completely different and before
and for me it was important before every
game
to go around and touch every player and
every equipment manager coach everybody
who worked in that organization because
it was an accountability thing like I
you know I gave you a pound or I test
you on your shoulder I shook your hand
I'm over to you and I'm accountable to
you
I do out here on the field and as I'm
doing that you know certain guys you
would have more of a conversation with
and Brandon Jacobs was right next to
Eli's Locker so I would go to Brandon
Jacobs yeah come on we run big run big
they don't want to hit you run big yeah
he be like yeah yeah yeah and then right
next to him is Eli and I just had to
look at Eli go have fun I just smile
that's our thing that's our thing
he's a Michael Strahan he partners with
Tom Brady and Gotham Chopra the
executive producers it's called
religionist Sports six-part documentary
series which premieres tonight at 8:00
Eastern and Pacific exclusively on the
audiance channel channel 239 on DirecTV
great to see you Mike thank you for
stopping by and not hurting any of the
Dennett's oh no I would not do that that
he's handsome guys a lot of facial hair
though going on yeah yeah fridge he's
having double hernia surgery tomorrow
but making fun of me saying is only
counts as one surgery but it's my groin
in my abdomen and they're just kind of
downplaying it like it's not that big a
deal
well you're growing yeah it's kind of
wine 130 table one time yeah so that's
considered 130 well they're very close
what if string just hit you fritzy and
maybe we just blow it out right now
can I just kind of punch the punch it
back can I ask you how you got got him I
had a previous surgery of course the
abdomen to get needed and the groin I
don't know how that happened but the
stuff we have right and no anything
physical Mike remotely athletic involved
yeah just hanging out of shape how long
you laid up I promised these guys that
hopefully I'll be back to the Monday
after Thanksgiving after the surgery
tomorrow they may actually I got to look
like we hope he takes more time off
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience